Dances with Wolves got 12 nominations
tonight we did some research some years
ago Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf got
13 so I think that wolf is the operative
word here folks so with that in mind I
see that the studio development reports
shows plans for the following remakes
inherit the wolf Fiddler on the wolf
wolves of endearment guess whose wolf is
coming to dinner citizen wolf dr.
strange wolf bang the wolf slowly and of
course who's afraid of dancing with
Virginia wolves huh
seventy pounds to present the next
category to of this evenings honorees
he's the new Godfather and she's a new
grandmother and she also was a Hornet
ladies and gentlemen Andi Garcia and
Whoopi Goldberg
we're talking sound effects here all
those things that go into a film to
create a mood or enhance the action
sound effects editing is a very precise
science thousands of snippets are
gathered synthesized blended and laid
down carefully in a plan to order this
is the nominees for sound effects
editing our Flatliners Charles L
Campbell and Richard Franklin the Hunt
for Red October Cecelia Hall and George
waters the second Total Recall Stephen H
flick and the Oscar for sound effects
editing goes to announce the winner
Cecelia Hall and George waters for The
Hunt for Red October
thanks to the members of the Academy for
honoring us thanks to my family for
their encouragement love and support
thanks to John McTiernan and mace new
fell for sharing their movie with us our
terrific editors Denis ver Claire and
John right our mixers Don Bassman Kevin
Clary dick Overton and Gary Rogers and
everyone we'd also like you'd like
everyone at Paramount Pictures Paul
Hager all of our great sound effects
editors ADR editor's Foley editors our
assistants everyone that really did a
great job thank you very much
when we return we'll continue with Jon
Bon Jovi Glenn Close and Dustin Hoffman